It’s an unusually calm moment in the SCP
Foundation.
No one is in the hall besides a scientist,
and a young female subject.
There are no tests going on, just observation.
The scientist calmly asks her questions as
he escorts her down the hallway, hoping to
get more insight into her unique abilities.
So why does she look so utterly terrified?
As the scientist tries to get her attention,
the young woman becomes more preoccupied,
staring nervously around the hallway.
Does she fear the scientist?
Why does she keep muttering strange phrases
that don’t make any sense?
“How did it break through such a heavy door?”
“That door is nearly a foot thick.
How did it manage to destroy it?”
The scientist is looking at his notes and
tries to make sense of the young woman’s
statements when he notices something terrible.
She’s staring at one of the doors containing
another, highly dangerous SCP in top-of-the-line
restraints.
But it’s safely locked away - right?
The scientist swears he can hear the sound
of scratching behind the steel door...
It was seventeen hours later when the dangerous
SCP broke out of its containment cell, and
could have laid waste to the entire SCP containment
facility - if it wasn’t for the heavily
armed response team waiting outside to contain
it and return it to its cell.
The huge loss of life was only avoided because
the SCP Foundation had advance warning.
All thanks to the greatest secret weapon the
foundation has ever seen, SCP-187.
But the Foundation’s most powerful defense
against dangerous SCPs is probably its most
unlikely - a completely normal-looking young
woman, in her early 20s, whose only distinguishing
characteristic is how thin and haunted she
looks.
Despite being no danger to anyone in the foundation,
she’s one of the most carefully guarded
SCPs in the facility - to protect her from
herself.
SCP-187 is one of the most powerful precognitives
ever found - but her abilities are a danger
to her own mind.
This average looking girl has a unique telepathic
ability where she can see into the future
of whatever she’s looking at - seeing it
simultaneously in two frames of existence.
She sees it as it is now, as well as what
it will look like in the future.
Say, for instance she’s looking at a baby
tiger cub.
Aww, cute.
At the same time, she also sees the massive,
fearsome jungle beast it’ll become.
She won’t see minor changes to its state
- so she won’t be able to tell you how your
next haircut will look - but if something
drastic is about to happen to someone or something,
she’ll be able to predict it with perfect
accuracy.
There’s only one problem - she can’t turn
it off.
This involuntary ability goes off whenever
she sees someone or something that’s about
to undergo a major change in its status.
This means that at any time, she can be bombarded
with horrible visuals.
And that even includes food.
Ever since her abilities kicked in, SCP-187
has been unable to eat normally because whatever
she eats or drinks, she sees in its future
state.
When she looks at a glass of water, she’ll
see it as liquid - but a little more yellow
than it usually is.
As for solid food, she’ll see it as what
it comes out as after it’s been digested.
Not exactly appetizing, so for a while it
looked like she was likely to starve herself
to death in the Foundation’s custody.
Fortunately, the administration’s scientists
were able to find some work-arounds around
her ability.
Feeding and hydrating her intravenously was
an option, but further study of her abilities
made clear that her power was processed through
her eyes.
That means that when she’s blindfolded,
she’s able to eat without her precognition
kicking in.
Being assigned to the detail for SCP-187 is
very different from most SCP details.
If you’re assigned to SCP-682, you’re
constantly worried that the horrible carnivorous
beast with a hatred for all things human is
going to get loose and tear you to shreds.
Not so much with SCP-187.
This duty is more like a medical team, where
the patient is highly valuable to the institution
and can’t be allowed to get free or to harm
themselves in any way.
The foundation has taken the highest precautions
to ensure SCP-187 is safe, including a set
of medical restraints that she’s strapped
into except when out of her cell or participating
in tests.
Even when given more freedom, her hands are
always in soft mittens - to keep her from
trying to damage her own eyes as a way to
neutralize her powers.
Her team blindfolds her before every mealtime
and feeds her, with some mild sedatives added
to her food to keep her calm.
Through consistent care, she’s starting
to recover from her self-induced starvation.
The personnel chosen for this assignment are
carefully screened before being sent in to
interact with her.
They need to be the most responsible and detail-oriented
members of the staff, who won’t miss a thing
when it comes to her care routine.
Just because 187 is harmless doesn’t mean
she can’t move fast, and one misstep could
cost the Foundation their most valuable asset.
And unlike most SCPs, 187 is rarely handled
by D-class personnel.
They don’t have access to higher-security
specimens, and they don’t have the training
due to their short tenure.
But there’s another reason the foundation
keeps 187 away from the lowest men on the
totem pole.
D-Class personnel are frequently used to test
out dangerous SCPs, and are lucky if they
get to the end of their service intact.
When she was exposed to some D-Class Personnel
early in her stay, she saw them as horribly
bloated, with holes in their heads, or missing
half their body.
Those unfortunate personnel soon met horrible
fates - sucked out into the vacuum of space,
shot while trying to escape, and bitten in
half by an escaping anomalous creature.
Additionally, while most D-Class Personnel
are amnesticized after their service, some
are terminated for breaking protocol or trying
to escape.
SCP-187 would see any of these unfortunate
personnel walking around as the corpses they’d
wind up as.
The Foundation wants to learn the full extent
of her powers though, and this means tests,
lots of tests.
When she first came into the Foundation’s
care, they were focused on figuring out how
her power worked.
They gave her IQ tests, and she got every
answer right on the written test.
Her IQ was measured as being off the charts,
at least 300, which would make her the smartest
person alive - but her normal behavior didn’t
seem to match up with this level of super
intelligence.
Confusing them even more, when she was given
a computerized IQ test, she scored slightly
below average - with a score of 97.
The scientists assigned to her case studied
the results and created other tests until
they understood how her precognitive ability
works.
She can see the future of anything that’s
physically affected.
So when an answer is marked down on a piece
of paper, that’s a notable change - but
when an entry is typed into a computer, the
computer remains the same.
So her ability wasn’t able to help her on
the computerized tests.
But her abilities could still help the Foundation,
especially when it comes to improving security
for other anomalies.
She had inadvertently prevented the escape
of an especially deadly SCP creature by predicting
it would break through the door, but how would
her powers manifest in more complicated cases?
Some Foundation researchers postulated that
she might be able to see into the future of
deadly, indestructible anomalies like SCP-682
and figure out a way to eliminate it, but
temporal experts warned this could create
a paradox.
After all, she would be looking at an elimination
protocol that didn’t exist until she looked
at it.
But her powers and how they might help in
other ways other than neutralization warranted
further exploration so personnel were assigned,
and the SCP-187 experiments began.
SCP-162 is a horrible mass of fish-hooks,
wire, and other sharp implements.
It exudes a psychological pull, and any unfortunate
person who touches it winds up being pulled
in by the barbed objects and absorbed into
its mass.
SCP-187 was kept at a safe distance and examined
it - and was undisturbed.
She saw it only as a pile of melted slag,
indicating that it would be neutralized at
some point.
SCP-529, a normal and friendly cat except
for the fact that its back half appears to
be completely missing.
The cat acts as if it’s whole, and when
SCP-187 was exposed to it, she didn’t seem
to notice anything wrong with the cat.
She played with it briefly, and seemed to
be calmer than any other time she was examined.
The Foundation is considering using SCP-529
as a motivating tool after she requested to
revisit it.
Other tests had much more disturbing results,
as SCP-187 discovered things about subjects
that researchers were previously unaware of.
SCP-003, a strange organic circuit board made
of hair and nails attached to a stone tablet,
appears to be an ancient machine.
But when SCP-187 was introduced to it, she
greeted it like a person and had a conversation
with it as the staff looked on confused.
When she was interviewed after, she described
the entity as “A very nice lady”.
What was SCP-003 evolving into?
The foundation is studying it closely thanks
to SCP-187’s advance warning.
When exposed to SCP-015, a massive network
of pipes that seems to be slowly growing and
defends itself from any attempts to work on
it with tools, SCP-187 observed few differences
from its current state - until she opened
a door.
Inside, she reported a massive network of
pipes reaching for miles, with no end in sight.
SCP-015 had been reduced to a manageable site
and its danger had been contained - but SCP-187
indicated that it may be getting ready for
its biggest and most dangerous expansion yet.
SCP-415, a seemingly normal human man with
an ability to regenerate his internal organs,
has been a subject of the Foundation’s investigations
since his arrival - particularly due to the
strange physical alterations he underwent
to make easier access to his organs.
He’s one of the more peaceful SCPs at the
foundation - but as soon as SCP-187 was exposed
to him, she became disturbed.
She begged to be removed from the room, and
upon interrogation, revealed that she saw
SCP-415 as a deceased corpse.
What is going to happen to the seemingly immortal
man?
SCP-187 was also exposed to some of the more
dangerous SCPs in the Foundation, including
SCP-173, a seemingly living statue that moves
in unpredictable ways whenever it isn’t
observed and has been responsible for the
deaths of many D-Class Personnel who enter
its enclosure for cleaning.
But it seems to be stable in containment.
So why, when exposed to it, did SCP-187 begin
screaming immediately, have to be removed
from the enclosure, and fall into a catatonic
state for two days?
She remembered nothing from the vision she
had of the statue, and it took days for her
to recover fully.
The foundation is keeping a close eye on the
statue, even closer than they were before.
SCP-106, also known as The Old Man, a depraved
killer resembling an elderly rotting corpse,
is known for its frequent escapes and sadistic
attacks on anyone near it.
When exposed to SCP-187, the observation lasted
less than a minute before the Old Man attempted
to escape.
SCP-187 looked to be in direct danger from
the Old Man, but he never touched her or harmed
her in any way.
When she was interviewed after, she explained
that the Old Man wanted an audience, someone
to watch it.
The incident was recorded as a close call
- and an indication that some of the other
entities may have their own plans for SCP-187.
SCP-187’s power works without fail, and
that tempts many people to try to use her
to get answers to important questions.
But they should be careful what they wish
for, as one Doctor found out during an examination.
SCP-187 looked at the woman’s hand and observed
that it was odd she wasn’t wearing her wedding
ring.
But the Doctor was - and had been for the
last nineteen years.
But the next day, her husband filed for divorce,
and SCP-187’s prophecies proved, once again,
correct.
So what are the future plans for SCP-187?
The Foundation is being careful with her abilities,
both to preserve her sanity and to prevent
any potential time paradoxes.
A routine has been established to keep her
safe, fed, and protected from some of the
worst effects of her ability.
But the experiments using her visions aren’t
going to stop any time soon.
Many of her visions predicted dangerous new
evolutions in Keter class anomalies, giving
the team time to prepare and up security measures.
No one knows where SCP-187 came from or what
the source of her unique abilities is, but
while the SCP Foundation is keeping some of
the most dangerous entities in the world safely
locked away, their most valuable asset may
be one of the most harmless.
Because as long as SCP-187 has her visions,
the next breakout or apocalyptic event can
be stopped in its tracks before it happens.
For more on some of the subjects SCP-187 interacted
with, check out “SCP-106 - The Old Man Escape”
or “SCP-173 - The Sculpture Tale”.